hello and welcome to the lobby game
spots weekly hangout every tuesday 2pm
pacific right here on videogames.com i'm
your host danny video games of wire and
i'm very happy to be joined by mark
video games walter
kevin van
video games
ord
and chris
video games waters
it's amazing the connection we all share
i know what a coincidence
i never thought our father really did
have sex with a lot of women
and then only gave us his middle name
it's very clear about it though i'm
saying video games a lot because in case
you guys haven't noticed
review team people a lot of video games
come out yo
you wouldn't know anything about this
would you not think
has been you feeling okay i
you know what i'm kind of tired
right now and uh i got lucky randolph
let me go home a little early yesterday
yesterday so i i took a nap i went home
and took a nap she's really tired and
now you're thinking about a better time
in video games 2000 2004 2004 like two
maybe just past half-life 2's
anniversary no 10-year anniversary so i
have to celebrate somehow how did that
happen like 20 i thought it was 20 i
think it's tomorrow 20th i i thought it
was uh internet sunday for some reason
siri
exploded
well no like people were celebrating
because halo 2 has its anniversary this
year of course you're right
world of warcraft is on warcraft you are
correct it was last sunday
so half-life 2 and wow came out within a
week of each other what a great time
that what a great time remember those
days
but it's still great times right here in
2014 because games such as grand theft
auto 5 far cry 4 and dragonage
inquisition
which all three of which we're going to
play uh today at the lobby punch games
didn't make it a little bit planner
three is out as well just came out yep
yeah what else is in the review pipeline
that dead island piece of garbage yeah
that's nice dead island pokemon pokemon
pokemon yeah forgot about pokemon
never alone never alone
yep what's that this war of mine
that game sounds rad it sounds like
everybody that likes games should play
this war of mine
wwe 2k15 on next gen console
will it be crap as well
find out later this week
um yeah there's loads man lego batman 3
yeah
batman i forgot about that space hulk
ascension i saw that go through qa what
the hell i have no idea what that is
it's just some warhammer thing we're not
40k okay you wouldn't understand
i wouldn't escape that on all of these
things it's crazy but we got we got too
many we'll talk about all the review
stuff later because i want to talk to
you guys a little bit about the sort of
the process and how crazy this whole
month has been uh but first of all mark
walton yes we had a review or you had a
review uh come through late last week
yeah and you played the bejesus out of
it uh and an old game
with a new mode gta 5 yes gc5 what a
great game it's a no it's a year old
it's old it ain't no half life too old
no yeah i mean so it's over a year old
they've updated it for ps4 xbox one it
is freaking great
it looks amazing
the best thing about it is like you know
you've got all these fancy new engines
people are starting to bring out for
like the playstation 4 xbox one they're
like oh look at all this stuff right you
know rockstar took their old engine
designed for the last gen updated for
this and it looks better than a lot of
those games and
gta on on 360 and ps3 was probably one
of the best looking games on those
systems i mean it pushed it pushed those
systems like further at least you know i
think so anyway from the way it looked
further than a lot of games did so yeah
yeah before we get into the bones of it
because we're going to play some here uh
the first person perspective thing there
was a really interesting sort of angle
to this that i didn't appreciate uh
until i read your uh review when we were
doing the video review was that when you
sort of go from the third person
perspective into like the head of these
characters
you
it feels more violent it feels more
weird or something yeah for me i think
it's
well what the crux of it was when i was
playing it was the first sort of big
heist and where it went a bit wrong and
you know and i'm having to gun down like
a lot of cops so i'm doing it all in the
first person and just don't because
you're sort of seeing it that way for
the first time there's like this
disconnect between you and the character
like when you're in third person so like
if you see trevor on screen and yeah
you're controlling him but he's the one
doing the shooting yeah okay right
you're like okay this guy's shooting
cops because he's a dick okay now
basically when you when you sort of zoom
into the first person all of a sudden
it's like okay
sure i'm still seeing the story as
trevor throughout the narrative in the
third person but now it appears like i'm
the one doing all the shooting and i
kind of feel bad and like you know you
were saying earlier about the sort of
stomping on people yeah like if you beat
people up and stomp on them it's quite
you stamp it on their head and you're
like looking at it like that it's like
when you like punch them they like their
glasses come off and they look shocked
yeah and like freaked out by you yeah it
does like it's weird how in for most
first-person games you walk up and like
bump like you get this close to someone
they just don't react because it's video
games you're like staring but in gta
because i don't know just the way
they've always made those worlds when
you walk up with someone they're like
you know what's going on yeah well they
might take a swing at you yeah or they
might hit you or something and all that
stuff that happens in first person now
but what's the difference like between
playing a game like payday 2 where
basically all you're doing is gunning
down cops when things go wrong to like
how does it why is it more impactful
when it's gta because
because gta creates a world and always
has done that is far more vivid and far
more realistic than most other shooters
like when you play call of duty it just
feels it's intentionally so but it's
very over the top and you know there's a
there's a sort of a fantasy element to
it and obviously the new one is a sci-fi
element to it but like you're in a war
zone yeah and they're bad guys
they're very very much the best yeah but
they were about shooting and also you
didn't drive there like stop and get
your hair cut exactly drive again and
then like get out and shoot a bunch of
cops like yeah it's more i get that
makes sense it's more detached from kind
of the the greater world yeah it feels a
little more gamey maybe yeah i mean gta
you know the the detail that is in gta
4's world is amazing five sorry and it's
it's that and the fact that you know the
voice acting is amazing the storyline
that drags you in the characters like
all that stuff adds up to you feeling
more like this is a real world so when
you are in it killing like innocent
people or cops or whatever it does you
know it moves you in a way that i don't
think third person ever did and when you
were speaking to like how you realize
in the story beats that you're like you
are trevor i kept having this thing i
played for about three hours last night
i kept having this thing where i forgot
which character i was right or i thought
i was michael and then so he's you know
he says something and you're like oh i'm
playing as trevor like i totally forgot
it just felt like me or like gordon
freeman or like
john halo you know it was like i am the
and then when you go up to like the
cutscene and the cutting kicks in you're
like oh it's taking me out again yeah i
guess because like it's particularly in
gta if you go off on one right if you
spend hours just driving around doing
that stuff with no sort of story
narrative in between to sort of bump you
out of it again i can see how you could
sort of feel like that you know you can
spend hours right just going around
killing stuff going to the desert trying
to find peyote and uh yeah exactly right
speaking of which uh let's do that uh
i'm guessing you're playing as trevor
right now i am trev as you were
trevor's a really like british name to
me i think
yeah um so yeah we're trevor this is his
place as you can see
uh he's staying at thingy's cousin's
place i've got his name completely
trashed this whole thing is so dark i
mean so in first person view i mean
immediately like what you see is just
like the detail that's on stuff that i
guess in third person you didn't quite
notice before like you just sort of go
through and just admire it it's a lot
easier to just look down on the
countertop and be like yeah oh yeah look
at that
drop some whiskey drink some whiskey
where is the whiskey and press the best
left on the d-pad it was right there
where would it be
yeah there you go
yeah let's have some shots yeah you can
really see all the all the blood and and
poo on the ground look at all the
whiskey in that glass and all the
pornography underneath the whiskey
delicious
ooh zoom in
there's enough filth in this game so
yeah i mean initially anyway that's one
of the cool things but like i was saying
the peyote is something that i didn't
realize was in this game hello uh that
was in this game um that lets you
transform into like spirit animals and
stuff yeah this is a new thing they've
put in um yeah into the hd version yeah
so we saw a youtube video earlier today
where uh somewhere near made chiliad
there was a um yeah like some sort of
yes peyote like a some sort of herb or
something
off your face peyotes like the stuff
they make from isn't that the stuff they
make from like uh cactuses okay like
maybe
i could be wrong i could be horribly
wrong about it but it's hallucinogenic
so
so do you want to go and try and get it
yeah totally you know give us a chance
to like drive through the city i'm gonna
get rid of this truck because i hate
this goddamn truck she's so slow
i'm gonna take this nice shiny fast car
okay here's the challenge you need to
get the chiliad right are you late
enough in the game where you can i have
do it in first person that's challenge
one challenge one i know driving in
first person i don't want to share sorry
push the wrong button you're doing good
options right i know driving in first
person is hard it's hard but just this
is one of my takeaways from this like i
love the detail on it though like the
speed officers that go around and stuff
but like it's really
hard man you cannot you cannot
get it around the corner very easily at
all it's really like twitchy like yeah
all right try and get to the airport see
if you can go to your hood all right so
let's where's the airport where's he
down there you go there we go all right
do you do you have a parachute at the
moment do you know uh probably not okay
let's try and get a helicopter if you
can't it's gonna be a little more
difficult but let's do it okay i'm gonna
be taking questions from the chat as
well uh and i also wanna tell people
that we're giving away a copy of uh far
cry 4. uh there's gonna be details on
that uh once we're finished playing gta
for our gta 5 here hang on we're giving
away far cry 4. yeah we're giving away a
special edition of this fun time i want
that game no you can't have it you're
ineligible anyone with video games as
their middle name can't win
damn it
do you know what i think it's higher has
gone out on this car i really think
that's what's happening sure yeah no
that's definitely yeah that's it that
must be it that's
do not be alarmed no
no fine i want that car
this isn't
especially difficult is trying to do
drive-bys in first person nope uh
get out first person blast the
motorcyclist and steal his bike
it is oh yeah okay
speaking of harsh oh i'm gonna if i fall
off this this is bad oh there we go
the other thing is that when i was doing
this in first person i forgot how like
health in gta works because you just
assume it's like every other fps you
just take a bunch of shots yeah one
headshot
hang out for a little bit yeah you'll
feel better i think the cops are after
me after shooting that motorcycle yeah i
got you know you got a star god nanny
stay there
i feel like this needs the thing where
like when you're driving you don't look
at the road directly in front of your
car you look at it like 40 yards in
front like the camera could use a little
bit of that stability
oh my goodness
okay
oh yeah if i drive past him we'll end up
running different trouble can you do you
have enough self-control to drive slowly
in gta just long enough for that car to
go away i think you need to go
downstairs here
go away there we go
so this is coming out on pc
january
end of january just
like oculus rift support is just going
to be the minute they come i didn't even
think of that
that would be amazing
right off they'll be fine
nailed it
look at that all right turn around turn
around yeah yeah you want to get in that
you want to get that exit by the
helipads so go straight oh yeah you're
right that's how you turn around right
there oh
oh god oh my goodness okay it's right
here left here left yeah yeah i think he
can probably drive up the steps and do
like ramp in on this thing
give it a go or maybe not oh no what's
that doing there you got to jump over
this
okay
i love the jumping in first person my
bike
oh combat roll fun times uh all right is
there a helicopter there okay now
they're pissed no they're seriously
pissed i should not be in here what a
good time for you too this is what
happens
so vigorously uh just in case
shots there's no choppers
where are the choppers can we steal a
little plane like the leader jet over
there yeah maybe look to your left is
there no chopper there oh no it looks
like this is that leader jack they're
gonna be busted
just land the jet when you get to your
destination no problem right on top of
that hopefully you have a
uh a parachute maybe
it's getting in i love how he gets in
first person as well this is great
up the stairs oh man
i'm not flying this i am going to fly
this in first place yeah try it oh no
you're going to have to it's so
difficult you're going to crash with all
that stuff
um shantan's asking you max out your
field of vision we can probably oh no
don't go forward back up i'm trying to
go back
i just can't
oh yeah there we go oh
dear
that looks like enough runway
up up and away
no big deal i believe in you come on
yes
someone tells me that was not an
authentic way to take off it's like so
hard to see where you're going though
we're gonna have to go third person for
this because i don't know first person
only we're gonna miss can i at least put
a waypoint on the map yeah sure right
because otherwise i won't know where i'm
flying and max at your field of just
going through the settings actually when
you're done here as well just to show
off some of the yeah i mean you can just
load the stuff like one of my favorite
things about this is because i don't
like driving in first person um you can
have the game automatically just like
remember your settings and that works
for individual vehicles so if you like
third person in cars you'll remember
that but if you like first person on a
bike you'll also remember that so it's
very very cool um and there's so much
customization like the controls you can
in third person you can have regular gta
controls in first person you can have
standard shooter controls so like sprint
is on the pushing the stick down instead
of tapping instead of tapping x which
just feels weird in first person because
you're having to take your your thumb
off like the other stick so like all
that kind of stuff like there's there's
loads of customization um field of view
is in here somewhere i just can't
remember what's in controls i think in
control yeah i i only because i did it
yesterday i think the field of vision is
that first person on foot field of view
yeah was one it was an option
yeah you're right oh it's like that
already max oh you've maxed out i did
sorry for yesterday's stream i did so
that's actually as wide as it goes okay
oh that's all right so we're doing the
map as well right where am i going where
am i going
up
yeah left in that like out there
no up a bit in that area yet
okay
kind of
do you have a i don't think you have a
parachute we should just try and jump
out of this just have a parachute you
have a parachute let's just see what
happens uh
it's so pretty it is pretty
uh chris that incredible amount of stars
though totally unrealistic for uh
underneath them
so is that bullet hole in there which
has clearly depressurized this cabin i
once i got the front windshield of this
thing like shot out and was just like
flying just like
the face cheeks are flapping
oh god level out level out there we go
it's pretty hard to see what you're
doing it is very hard do a barrel
is that wise
sure
well i guess that's not really barrel
though what is something called whatever
that is yeah nothing
pretty dope because a barrel roll you
have to like trace the inside of a
circle right is that the idea
that's a role sure sure
i don't know
i feel like i saw some vlogs about this
i know this is going to go really wrong
i i don't see any way we're going to get
out of this plane in these mountains
without dying horribly apparently it's
not with that attitude okay
but apparently it's close to i think
it's on its own but peak to the right
there's a cable car up there yep so if
you get out there
like at the peak of the mountain also is
your landing gear still down oh yeah
that's fine gonna leave it down i don't
want to risk it right let's just
leave it down
and everything will be fine i'm pretty
sure that's not proper flight procedure
oh fine just up this up there we go no
nice work okay i'm impressed you knew
how to do that with the controller yeah
it was a muscle memory
i've been playing it yeah all right
you did spend most of the weekend yeah
exactly uh okay just think about that
hot peyote up there i'm just gonna get
you okay we seriously need a game plan
right i'm approaching if you have the
mountain
bank up
and if you have the parachute this will
be really easy and if you don't
it'll be pretty funny he's pretty
confident he doesn't have
i'm 90 wouldn't it be like in here oh
god i can't even get into the menu up
here you can't even see if you're over
the mountain anymore i feel like you
might want to just bring it down so that
well no you're still gonna hit the
ground ease it down there you go oh my
god way to ease
oh that's it
i think you're gonna stop and roll
yeah
just cruise right
oh
oh that was so close did you end up like
tumbling down yeah
if it just not if he'd missed that first
roll i would have made it
oh man you should try to try and get up
there again we've got we've got a plane
uh you should be if you like respond
nearby right because yeah
or if you oh yeah it will like country
hospital yeah yes or police station
whichever and then you go to the
airfield up there they sometimes have an
airplane or a helicopter yeah all right
trevor's test it out let's do that uh
yeah this is all in the the goal is to
take peyote right right yeah okay pretty
much that's that's pretty much all our
goals what we're trying to do and then
there will be fun and good times on the
way right that's the bucket list right
there okay so uh trevor's
one oh you could probably just take the
cable car up actually yeah let's go over
to the cable car perfect all right
i think you have to wait around for it
but whatever yeah public transit
actually while we're doing that isn't
there like some sort of mystery i think
there's like
the mount chiliad mystery
oh it's in that cable car yes
yes there is this like a new mission or
something no or some kind of easter egg
this is something that everyone was
going on about from like uh
by the way that's entirely your fault
there is a new murder mystery in this
though oh there is some sort of ghost
thing yeah which is um
which
i can't remember if it's only for people
that have it on on the last gen and then
brought it on this one
but um yeah there's like a new murder
mystery set of missions for michael
which is quite cool i mean there's a
bunch of new stuff right it's hard to
just sort of talk about everything new
in the store yeah because it's not
they're not like big grand features like
first person is but the rest of it is
just little things that you're gonna
pick up on as you play through and
um
yeah it's cool isn't it these just
killing me this is great
like this is i think i had that car
not even gran turismo could get all the
interiors in their game no and they
spent like nice oh god you got it
oh we made it so far it's okay he's used
to driving on the other side
he's fine that's first-person cycling
everyone's like i'm nailing it
are you using the rear-view mirror is
that you looking backwards yeah that's
great oh my god
are you parked up this there you go a
little bit close enough what what's the
first person bicycle like not too shabby
the first person oh yeah i've done that
before so it's like um
it's not a hammer x but yeah
there we go
yeah it's a bit
all right
okay i'm gonna go and ditch the bike get
off the bike there we go
so many guns yeah just shoot one of
these cars up
you're trying to get to the top we're
trying to get to the top and he's
getting the cable car scare everyone oh
my god oh geez
unprovoked
it's fine
this is so nasty because oh the cable
car's gone
it's all these people this is what
happened
this is what happens when you take the
time to you know murder people yeah as
sean mcinnes would say no witnesses
do you reckon they can't blame i blame
this person oh god for the cable car not
being there
it's a good job i'm a well-adjusted
person really because otherwise
first person video games
what have you done so annoying you did
take a long way around oh i gotta go
stamina should be up
there you go before the popo come
get him getting in okay
you got it go go go got it
damn you trevor in your broad shoulders
there it is oh getting gonna get it yes
it's all gone wrong stay in there and
hide yeah it's fine
stealth mode is that their cover this is
stealth no cover would be
that
where is it
cover would be no you only murdered like
one person you mentioned the cover was a
little finicky
go go
and scoot your butt up they'll never see
you they're definitely coming up there
are they definitely
yeah i think they're there just keep
hiding keep fighting go stand there stay
in there yes yes yes
justice should we skip the ride or do we
want to admire the views of you oh no
you said yes you said in my other view
okay don't fall off yeah fine don't fall
off
okay now i think you want to go is look
it left look at that see that you see
the lighting effect on there like you're
right you're in here and it's like and
it's super bright the hdr
um so look at the rocks right they're
rumblier
yeah it really looks way more like
alternatives
it's a technical term you guys uh so
there should be a little red flag turn
to the left i see it you see it oh okay
good work okay we did it i think that's
it yeah i think this is it yeah this is
it because there's the sign oh yeah
what does it say
see what they did there
um that's some hot uk joke
there okay so this is come on paper
what are you going to transform into
what do we get what do we got it's like
a random animal it's quite red i'm told
it's random so
oh we're a bird
oh wow
press r2 for aerial attack
are you gonna the birds oh dude let's
get crew from somewhere you gotta go
firecracker
this is so dumb
it's pretty dumb it looks amazing
there's no first person bird mode this
is the future
first nerdsome no you want to get third
person for adam what's his fan crow
what's up
my god i just saw you poop you really
need to go poop on someone oh right we
gotta go find someone we are quite far
away from everyone what about on top
there's usually people on top right like
tourists
oh no i've gone
oh no i'm going down
too late
les moonves in the gamespot chat says i
approve of this senseless slaughter
thanks boss
get the go-ahead from on high
see apparently what is it like 27 of
these or something yeah so there's like
27 different animals like so fast people
have found seagull
uh chicken
um
i think that's it crow crow yeah we
found the crowd they're all just
variations on birds
pigeon hey pigeons one although if
penguins want that even better and maybe
there is penguin like if you go down by
the water and stuff should be really
great yeah it's just going to be like in
the aquarium there's no penguin habitat
in los santos
is there a zoo there's no zoo is there
i don't think it's a zoo and sounded
right why is there not a zoo
that's oh my god that seems like an
oversight oh there you go well you know
sorry i didn't realize i could push x to
make it go faster okay because i'm used
to the
first person oh yeah
there we go
it is probably the worst place for you
to get peyote and do this oh my god
are the cameras killing you're going
through this
you're going to this lonely road
at least angle towards those buildings
emotion sickness is like
imagine this in oculus rift no
i do not wish to imagine that
when was the last time you got like
legit motion stick from the game kevin
actually i i found that over this review
season i spent so much time doing
nothing but playing games there came a
point where my brain just started to fry
all right
but typically
the occult bird
so a bad frame rate can really hurt can
actually make me motion sick when i play
games so but tip it like pray is the
last time i actually had like a game
mechanic really
like going up walls and upside down yeah
pretty much yeah going like traveling up
like this and having the whole room like
basically the wall become the floor and
stuff like that like that [__] really
oh dear here we go here we go
all right we're getting close you're
gonna dirty some windshields
yeah
this is just the dominant it's so dumb
although did you see the goat simulator
expansion pack that's coming out yeah
the mmo thing that's actually still
being so what is that sorry dumbest
thing of the week they're making there's
like a free expansion pack for gold
submitter coming out which turns it into
like a fantasy mmo oh yeah amazing
there's 101 levels
yep so you can level up to 101 new level
cap uh
you can suppose like five characters you
can select okay i think they're
different goats and one of them is just
a microwave on legs
it's like two really yeah it's like a
microwave with two human legs on it yes
oh man if you could attack a
motorcyclist oh this is really hard to
control you you're gonna get lost you're
gonna get hit by a car is what's gonna
happen just go into the village
there's terrible
oh no
god damn it
you're the world's worst crowd oh my
goodness
what a way to end your spirit journey is
that the only bit of payout up there is
there anything done
out of 27. we got one or 27. what the
hell
you're still coozed up are those bikes
up there coming down can you take it
again or does it just no it's gone now
it looks like it's just a collectible
you do it once and that's your that's
your chance
good job mark sorry
go back up and see if you're gonna cycle
off the top of the map way to waste
your life has no meaning
oh
uh out now on xbox one and ps4 and then
we'll be coming soon to xbox or sorry to
pc next january exciting mods indeed
yeah oh my goodness
so many games
we've already had a hell of a bunch of
games drop over the past couple of weeks
this is kind of silly season for
reviewing type folks like you wonderful
gentleman uh kevin what's it been like
well i'm actually kevin's clone okay uh
it takes a few kevin's to
real kevin got terribly motion sick and
had to be admitted to long-term care
true
it's always the rough time right and of
course we we a little bit smaller
staffed than we were at the same time
last year versus why mark's over helping
us out as well good job mark thank you
thanks for coming over bringing your uh
your british charms thank you
for the us yeah
america so
what's this better each other day has
this been heavier than last year well
yes in the s and in the sense that of
course we have fewer people so it's
actually kind of hard to like i spend so
much of my time there's no real
right now there's no real difference
between like when i'm working and when
i'm not working it's just like i'm
always just kind of working if that
makes any sense like i just you know and
plus you know so much of what we do
depends on when we receive things from
publishers so it's like you're just kind
of stuck doing it when you get it and
then us deciding how to kind of deal
with deadlines and things like that this
timing is a super crunch because you
know you're dependent on maybe you get
some code early but then if you do there
are embargo times or certain limitations
to what you can show given the embargo
time and then releases stacked on top of
one another especially and even from the
same company i mean companies like 2k
games like ubisoft release like they
have their own releases like week after
week after week well think of it this
way like we had two
so we had two assassins creeds on one
day and then a week later we have a far
cry i mean ubisoft is basically just
saying okay we're done now here's a
we're gonna poop the games right on
right out there and here you go so
originally the crew was gonna be coming
out
right so
it would it could have been even worse
and of course a lot of these games are
huge it's not like you know i mean call
of duty or something notwithstanding but
you've got like far cry is huge and
assassin's creed is huge and dragon age
is huger yeah and uh so these aren't
just little things i mean sometimes you
get a you know you get a six hour
shooter you can finish it in a day yeah
these aren't things you can finish in a
day and of course they all they all show
up on the same day just
plop on my desk i was like here you go
thanks so talk about the process because
i feel like one of the biggest
misunderstandings people have about like
how large game sites work is like how
much heads up we have how much time we
have the embargo stuff like who gets to
review them
so what what's the past couple of weeks
been like in terms of like just getting
games and then figuring out how we're
going to review them on time well the
first bit is is like trying more or less
to kind of
have a plan about who's going to do what
the problem is of course that we can
only do so much like we have a plan and
then things come in at one time or
something or something comes
much later than we expect and so the
plan gets disrupted so so but we
typically have a good idea of who knows
what games and the good news is that all
of us play
lots of different games so it's rare
unless it's something like a fighting
game or something very specific like a
wrestling like wwe or a sports game or
something typically any of us for
example we all played far cry so you
know that kind of thing you know isn't
too much of a problem when that comes in
but we more or less had people earmarked
like i sort of knew that we were gonna
you know because you know me or randolph
uh ramsay my boss will talk to
you know the pr people in advance that
are in charge of getting us games and so
ub for example is really good about
giving us a more or less a pretty good
timeline of what wins something's going
to come and then we can plan around that
and this year
aside from call of duty there wasn't
really any event to go to yeah um we got
the games
um in some cases that means we get a
debug copy
for people that don't know that's
basically the final disc but it runs on
a on a test kit rather than a retail kit
because it hasn't gone through
manufacturing so it doesn't have all the
you know all the copy protection layers
on it and stuff
um but usually like in the case of
dragon age which i'm going to be playing
soon is it we just got retail in advance
yeah bioware's like here you go
play some
enjoy what if they did that three days
later or five days later things can be
different yeah i mean things can be
tough i mean but the good news is most
folks are really good this time of year
about giving us a game in advance
although that's not
always the case isn't mark no this is
true it's not always the case i mean
assassin's creed rogue was um a good
example of that um that just sort of
didn't turn up yeah yeah that just
wasn't said unity did unity did
did turn up in advance so you know i
just had quite a lot of time with that
um but rogue was just here it is it's
sound release day we went and bought the
game and then i went and just happened
through and played as much as i could
and did some side quests and things you
know when you sort of
i guess with these games you know
particularly a story based game it is
always about seeing the entirety of that
story and making sure that you're seeing
everything that you think people would
see and do when they play that game and
trying to give it its fair share um and
trying to do that you know with a
deadline and all that kind of stuff can
be difficult but and the interesting
case studying with grand theft auto then
because we got it at the end of last
week yeah um you were playing it all
weekend yeah i caught the video review
on sunday yeah so we'd hit the like
their embargo for that review was 3 a.m
because they figured once new zealand it
hits midnight we'll just do a global
embargo whereas like sure that's kind of
weird i mean gta is a slightly different
beast in that it is not a new game yeah
effectively you know this is the same
they haven't changed the story or
anything like that they put in some new
missions but the core of that game is
exactly the same so i i played gta 5
already all the way through to the end
and did a lot nearly 100 of it basically
so coming back to this gta 5 you know
slightly different process you know it's
not about getting to the very end of the
game seeing the entire story because we
know that we know what's happening in
that game we know how those characters
work what's important is figuring out
you know what are the new things here
how well do they work what are you
getting as someone that may already own
the game and now want to upgrade to this
new version you know and it's getting
that stuff across and rockstar is at
least i mean the embargo they gave is
sensible yeah um i mean it would have
been nice to have the game before we got
it because it meant for a lot of
crunching over the weekend yeah but
there there are cases where and people
are talking about this a lot this year
and i suspect or at least hope that
maybe publishers will take a second look
at what embargos are because sometimes
we'll get an embargo um and so for
people that don't know what embargo is
basically like the publisher is like
okay in exchange for giving you the game
early we're going to set an embargo
meaning that you we don't want you to
post your review earlier than so and so
time and so we that's that's part of the
agreements like we get the game early
both your review post game play talk
about it on right here when you're
allowed to do this stuff it's like that
professional courtesy kind of yeah
exactly
but when you get something that's like
it can go up 9 00 a.m pacific time on
tuesday you know you're talking about uh
you're talking about nine hours after
the game has been out already on the
east coast depending on the game people
might have gone and bought it and
finished it before you your review will
ever go up and
you know in some you know we'll push
back against that stuff but sometimes we
can't we don't necessarily get anywhere
but the more people pay attention to
this stuff especially um when the game
then comes out and it ends up being
broken yeah for example um then um that
that puts us in a tough position
but like there's a weird scenario this
week with with uh some i know total
biscuit and a couple of other pc gamer
said they didn't get versions of far cry
4 and then we're suddenly doing like
tweeting that as if almost like i felt i
felt really quite angry about it because
i thought what you're doing there is
basically sort of blackmailing the
developer to like send you the game
because you're implying that there's
something wrong with it like whether or
not there is or isn't but the
implication though like we didn't get
that's really tough you have to be
careful because i mean in the movie
industry you'll have the same thing like
there's no advanced screening that often
if not most of the time means that but
i've i mean we've been doing games long
enough where i i know that there there's
nothing necessarily implicit in the same
thing in games typically in movies you
know that it's probably going to be crap
but in the case
of games that's not really the case so
for example we didn't get we didn't get
lego batman
well in advance we typically haven't
been getting lego games in advance for
example so you know i remember getting
valkyria chronicles not at all yeah
there are some games we just have to go
out and and we gotta ban edit two like a
month earlier yeah we got banned in like
more than a month mario is what mario
kart we had for mario kart like so in
the uk like nintendo quite good at
sending the code out so bayonetta i had
for like at least two and a half months
right before that game came out they
they had for that so they have different
embargoes with bayonetta there'll be
some preview ones there'll be some
review ones yeah yeah i just played
through the whole thing
that one's weird nintendo's funny too
because i mean at this point most
publishers sort of understand the
internet's a global thing right nintendo
will do embargoes where it's like we
have this embargo in europe and this
embargo and it can be really odd because
they'll they'll have embargoes like in
in europe like a you know days if not a
week earlier than the us
um
and they'll say okay you can't do it if
a u.s reviewer does it but you can put
it up if
your uk reviewer does it but it's going
to the same place yeah the internet
nintendo's kind of weird and
then there's of course you know
part of embargoes is like here's a list
of spoilers we don't want you to put in
for example pokemon and nintendo which
is great to read right
here's a game uh so excited for you to
play it here's a list of all the
spoilers we don't want you to talk about
but we're just going to put it right
so a lot of games will come with a
reviewer's guide which promptly gets
shoved somewhere that i never look at
until i'm done with the game so
especially with something like dragon
age yeah where it's like here's a list
of things we don't want you to reveal
it's like but i don't want you to reveal
it to me
so i'll play first and then i'll go back
and and and check and see what those
things are and of course even sometimes
then they'll reveal something that i
didn't come across because i didn't go
down that particular story path or or
whatever but uh and with stuff like
pokemon nintendo's really weird like
we'll get sometimes we'll get like pages
of like here are all the pokemon you
can't mention her in the game you can
only mention things that happen in the
first three chapters you can only you
know and that and so what we'll actually
do sometimes is then go back and do a
second a second thing yeah um once the
initial we we've done that with a video
review for pokemon before i remember ign
did something really funny once in a
pokemon review where they were just like
big black retards
over everything they weren't allowed to
talk about in the review and then they
just took them out
when uh that's right when the game was
actually released so it's
you know this stuff can be weird and
funny and
sometimes they get the game they
sometimes they get the game early to you
and it's a game that you you familiar
with and you play a lot and then some
weird online jiggery pokery happens that
like
causes the problem like when do we post
this the halos
crazy
halo the master chief collection was a
whole different beast because it
combined the sort of uh you know oh well
i've kind of played these games before
that mark experience with gta 5 like you
didn't need to play
all of gta 5 to write the ps4
xbox one review uh so i didn't complete
every campaign in the in the master
chief collection all four halos before
reviewing it but you played it a lot
though i played it a lot uh and that was
weird because because it was a digital
copy of the game they sent us uh we got
the campaign
first and had those for most of a week
and then they patched in the multiplayer
stuff uh and then they did that like
12 hours before the review embargo
lifted which was the thursday before the
actual game came out and the servers
went live so that's another question
when it comes to reviews is
online can i test online in a like
environment that's reasonable that i
think is going to approximate the the
reality when this game comes out with
halo the servers i mean they went on but
they were very scarcely populated so
developers will like organized times
like hey come on by friday from like
three to six we'll have a bunch of
people there playing uh but with halo
what they were doing was custom games
inviting you in so you could play the
game and you could like get a feel for
playing halo 2 multiplayer classic or
anniversary which was a trip like
swimming between those two um
but at the same time you're playing
custom games and you know you're not
testing the online architecture so for a
game like that what we did this time was
the review in progress sort of an update
talked about the campaigns but then
i we held off on the online multiplayer
until we could see how it went and
sometimes holding off on that is like
not a great move because then you don't
have your complete review you don't have
your review score up when everyone's
looking for it yeah hitting embargoes
the thing we didn't really touch on is
really important for us because that's
when everyone wants to see the game
that's when like the audience comes for
it and if it's not there then
you're not people aren't coming to your
site as often if they don't think you're
if you're not hitting those embargoes um
so we held it
come tuesday the servers go up
they're not up i mean anyone who tried
to play i got tweets from people who
like went and bought it at midnight
stayed up for four hours got into like
two matches and like that's brutal and
but you also understand like okay
we've seen it a bunch of times before
online our infrastructure you know you
can't really test what it's gonna be
like in the retail environment to that
scale sometimes stuff happens totally so
you know gave it a couple days gave it
all last week and held the review until
saturday uh but finally
it wasn't like the patches they were
administering were not fixing it and
didn't get better they actually took
away options on the multi-player so yeah
like you can't just choose to go in and
play halo 4 multiplayer now right you
could maybe get into a match as part of
a big team battle playlist but
like that's a major thing it kind of
sucks
it sucks it totally sucks and then it's
reflected in the review and then it's
reflected in the review and so that's
why the game got a six uh and a lot of
people are outraged because there's this
enduring fallacy that like
uh a game i will play is a seven or
above a six or below is a total garbage
pile that you know was created by
masochistic demons that just want to
torture me like that is so wrong and
that's not the way we write our reviews
here like a six if you're ignoring a six
just because of the number you're
missing a lot of
numbers are always tricky and forever
games games writers will be talking
about numbers and whether reviews should
have numbers whether stars are better
than numbers whether we should use a
number of bananas whether the number
should change whether the number should
change over time this is harder it's
harder yeah yeah i mean how to how to
read how to take care of games and how
to handle games as they you know
you know change over time i mean we're
used to that in things like say in mmo
or something like diablo 2 or whatever
but then we have now i mean now and
every game is essentially subject to
this and i even tweeted earlier today
that i that i miss when games were just
released rather than launched because
we're now at a stage where we talk about
things like the halo master chief
collection
launch
are we even talking about games like
this as
launching like that that kills me but
so that's why like when it comes to
reviews everything's just like on a
case-by-case basis and we have to you
know the reviewer has to look and say
you know when's
you know yes it's it's okay to do this
but even then we know that that doesn't
mean that you know maybe when that game
goes live the the day it goes live that
it will be perfect and that's happened
before and it's happened before and
sometimes if we're in the process you
know sometimes that means we just can't
evaluate something and we have to wait
um at least to at least attempt but then
we have to draw a line in the sand and
it's like how far do we go before it's
like it's not okay anymore we have to we
have to review this um i had a
discussion for example yesterday with uh
with dan hines in the
in the australian office who's reviewing
never alone
um because the game's just straight out
broken
um and then of course there's also
another issue which is that he's in
australia the patch is hit at different
times yeah and these are these are just
the sort of things that we have to we
have to work around now in in games
where that just never was a thing you
know 10 years ago for example and then
obviously like making sure that you
understand where the bribes are coming
from who's paid you off
because i think there's so much like
misunderstanding about the realities of
actually doing this i mean typically all
that happens is hey here's you know
we have to plan kind of in advance when
the busy time comes because we sort of
have to know so i do talk to people at
ea and ub and stuff like that but you
know what happens all that is an email
and say somebody sends me hey we've got
dragon age coming to you so and so dan's
like okay cool i can plan around that i
get an email and say so we're sending
far cry this day and blah blah i don't
know yet about when we're gonna get
because a lot of times pr people don't
know yeah like when they're gonna have
access to games and they're they're kind
of you know it's a long chain for them
before it ever comes to us
and then but most of the time it's like
oh i got a game in the mail
or hey this game's coming out next week
and it's a week earlier and i still
don't have it so i'll shoot you know hey
hey when can we expect to get so and so
thing particularly just like it comes to
me i know who's available it's like
here's here's your review game for
review and and of course now most of our
reviews are done by people by by
contracted officers that don't even
freelance even in the office we've got
some great freelancers and then but then
that also complicates the question of
once the reviews posted and this is
something that's come up a lot with the
halo review is
what happens as the situation changes
like when 343 industries gets it
together and like all of a sudden you
can get into a halo match like that and
whatever uh does the score change is the
review updated and then how does that
change when it's me in-house versus a
a freelancer who then you maybe have to
pay them to do another updated review
and maybe their schedule is full you
know uh so in the case of halo you know
like in the case of updating reviews you
have a couple ways to do that one is to
just sort of put an editor's note in the
text of the review so people going to
read it in a month we'll see a different
you know the whole review will be there
it's entirety but there'll be an extra
note yeah like an addendum or something
yeah and so we did that with uh
titanfall earlier this year which is a
review i did um we also do second take
reviews and other perspective reviews
though uh the bandwidth for that given
our carter
the famous one was the league of legends
one because when that game first came
out it was a it was a pile of trash it
didn't maybe
originally league of legends six but
that was another thing because back then
we didn't review free to play games yes
specifically as a retail package
but you know even then like we view
even now like a second take is different
from an updated review so an updated
review would be like the league of
legends review which is like or we did
we've done it with lots of other games
like eve online for example there's
another one that we did whereas second
takes is is really not so much about how
much has the game evolved but like
different i have a different perspective
on this game and we're gonna share it so
for example when randolph did disney
infinity
and it was like this is you know i
played it as a game i play with my kids
so i have a different i have a different
perspective than than kevin and also
kevin is wrong
a lot of balls to juggle yeah
yeah i mean it's and and people will
sometimes ask how come there's no video
review or how come this review came then
or you know this review got posted
before this one are you saying this
stupid game i've never heard of is more
important than major blah blah blah it's
like it's
i mean it's it's work right like like
it's a lot more complicated than just i
decide that this game is more important
than this game um you know when you have
you know a certain number of people you
know you have certain resources you have
uh you know there's lots of stuff
involved like when we get the game do i
have to send it to somebody off site we
run into situations like okay so i have
somebody pegged to do wwe is a great
example like i have somebody pegged to
do this review that's off-site because i
don't really have anybody in-house
and so that i i have an author that can
do it justice
and
he only has a playstation 4 so even
though we might ask for playstation 4
copy we get xbox one yeah and so that
that seems like such a and then the ps4
won't arrive and then the ps401 arrives
but we need i need but the video team
needs footage so now i'm playing wwe
right in my evenings to get the footage
for when we record the video and then it
comes friday night so that's not you
know if i overnight it you know it
doesn't necessarily give the author as
much time as so these are the kinds of
things that happen this is just one game
like these kinds of things can happen
with you know lots of games in a week
and it's just a it's just a juggling act
so when you don't see a review or when
you see this review post before this
review or when like one thing has a
video interview one thing doesn't um
it's just that this it's all this stuff
all kind of combined into one pot and
it's it's a lot and if you guys i mean
if you have questions about it i've been
answering a lot of questions on twitter
about my halo review and if you guys
have these questions like reach out to
us we're on social media for a reason
like you know at the our bylines and
every review is a link to our profile on
gamespot and so you can send us messages
that way so this is stuff that we try we
try to be transparent about you know
writing about the circumstances of the
review within the review itself is like
not you know we try to do something
like at the bottom of the review so uh
yeah if anything's ever not clear we're
here for you guys yeah and and it's
usually easiest i mean it's interesting
because uh it's hard for me to answer
messages on gamespot per se because
eventually like i'll just have thousands
of things in there um just because of
the way the messaging system works and a
lot of other stuff so
and and sometimes i'll get stuff on psn
or xbox live and i'm like i can't really
res i'm not responding this way yeah
but if you you know sending me an email
is easy it's always a response it's
there in my byline or it's easy because
it's kevinv gamespot.com we're on
twitter we're on fiddle cub super super
easy um to send me a message that way
i'll answer it you know there's really
no i mean i i you know i just want to
unveil this kind of stuff i can be as
transparent as i can be if you've got a
question just just ask
if it was something that we didn't cover
in this exhaustive conversation
so you're better we'd better keep you to
imagine yeah thank you so much though
for uh for talking to us about that
talking to me about that talking to
everyone about that but first of all i
want to talk to you guys about this
piece of magician with craziness uh this
is far cry 4 key rat edition i actually
don't know what the hell's in it can we
open it without opening it i don't know
see if this might not be
okay so in the collective box you have a
propaganda poster the box itself so you
can put it up in a medium
uh a travel journal
uh
a map of kyrat a pagan min 20 centimeter
figurine which is of him i don't know if
i can get that to the camera it's him
sitting in his elephant throne yeah they
got rid of the the the weird slave thing
they had yeah elephant thrown girl for
the best there's the poster
camera
yeah this way there we go
thank you let's shine there we go so
you've got it
there's the statue uh there's the poster
uh that way is the journal this is
really like this is much harder than it
looks okay and if you want to win this
all you have to do is there was a tweet
that went down probably about 40 minutes
ago now
on gamespot.com um if you retweet that
make sure you're following us then uh
you'll be in a chance to win that bad
boy so retweet the tweet and follow at
gamespot and uh yeah we'll be giving it
away during the show right now so do it
because you might have a chance to win
the game comes north right the game you
can't game as well because it's not one
of those stupid collector's editions
no freaking game i think it might be
which is why we have the game
okay okay
does it say sold separately this is no
stupid wolfenstein thing you get
exclusive uh you get exclusive stuff in
it as well exclusive stuff
in-game stuff kirk's redemption
redemption parks redemption although
he's holding he there's like a there's
like a harpoon gun that he's holding
like prince was holding his guitar the
super bowl performances
like lynched them battler man it never
gets old uh okay this game looks kind of
rad nine out of ten this game is really
really a couple of days ago
in a second so i am not a dragon age fan
i really really really really really
really like that no i have i tried the
first one i played it for a few hours
didn't catch on but i've been playing
this and i really really really yeah so
i'm in that similar situation where i
played the first one i think i was
expecting something closer to mass
effect and i didn't get it and it turned
me off and then i heard two wasn't too
harsh the combat system was a bit messed
up or whatever but between you playing
this the review and andy baumann playing
it beside me in the office um i'm really
interested to play it yeah this game's
pretty rad i really really really really
like this we've said really a lot
as a writer i understand that you have
to use strong words to really
communicate and in the absence of strong
words you just use just these responses
you know
in the worst uh so loading screens i
know yeah it's not we just cut to it
here we go
can i give a big a big spoiler warning
though before we begin okay so my save
is post story save here okay so i'm
gonna do my best not to
show or do anything that reveals
anything important okay but it is
important for me to note that it is
possible that something that shows up
might be
you could consider it a spoiler would it
be something really obvious so shouldn't
you just go wander around in the
hinterlands or something yeah that's
what i'm going to do is probably just go
to an area gtfo yeah just go away from
the place where you talk to the people
why are you a little pixie person you
can create your own character yes you
can and this is my inquisitor he's an
alpha daily shelf
um
dalish he's danish so that means he's uh
he's from denmark
i'm sorry
like you said english
so like for someone like me right
the thing that puts me off these games
is because i've never really been into
the whole fantasy dungeons and dragons
his swords and elves and and that kind
of i've never been into that kind of
world right i mean even skyrim or stuff
even scott yeah yeah skyrim and things
like that so you know that's why i like
mass effects as sci-fi i love sci-fi so
like for someone like me i mean is it
even worth bothering like because it is
very much heavily in that fantasy world
right
yeah yeah see i'm not into that i'm not
necessarily into that stuff either but
like i love skyrim i love that stuff
yeah yeah i'm into it i love lord of the
rings that's totally my jam all right
all right is this a game that people who
haven't played dota 2 can dive into it
stop scrolling through all the names
i'm doing my best look i'm trying to get
the people i want just use i'm sorry
again like this
it can be slightly spoilery so what were
you doing um so i was choosing a party
um it's basically gathered my party and
venture forth um so i decided not to go
to the hinterlands because bioware has
shown so much hinterlands okay um in
advance so i'm going to the storm coast
um which is one of the earlier places
that you'll unlock and i have my
favorite party members with me
um so i have of course me
and i have cassandra um now if you don't
because this is the first time
cassandra's been a member of your party
but cassandra is the is the um
you know the woman that
inquisited um varric at the very
beginning of dragon age 2. so you will
you will know her even though you
haven't necessarily played her so do you
always play with four people well i can
choose to play with fewer
mad but that but if i want an extra
challenge but i i'm not doing that in
this particular case so here we are on
the storm coast now as you as you travel
oh there's uh by the way that's uh
you don't often need this but you do
have your overhead uh which also lets
you get like glamour shots let's zoom in
and see some iron bolts yeah yeah is
this photo mode oh yeah i love iron bowl
iron bowl is so great he's freddie
prince junior right pretty cool what
is the voice actually that's i
want to say it is but somebody correct
me because i could be just being really
really stupid
um oh kevin but i'm gonna go to the map
and i'm gonna go off to places i haven't
really been
yet is it always raining on the storm
coast or does it actually stop it's
usually rainy okay at very least so
talk to us a little bit about the world
is it these kind of instance levels so
it is instanced in the sense so in in
that sense it's it is a lot i'm sorry i
have to get stoned i can't not get it
so this is this is basically my little
uh tactical shield thing that i can drop
it always uh
oh no no that uh that is a dispel that i
just cast there
to get rid of anything there's so much
magic happening here it is too much
so a lot of that is just kevin's basic
magic attack that he's just
slinging out yeah so this is my basic
magic attack but this is what i meant to
do the first time around so this is does
it pause
because you chose that spell or are you
choosing the tactical cat like version
because you can press at any time
the tactical camera you can just pause
it and it pauses yeah when you go up
like that at pause and now you can
switch between your account
i mean you can you don't have to be in
tactical view to do this right um but uh
you know if i wa if i want to start
micromanaging this is this is where i go
if you want to go look at somebody
getting whacked in the face by a giant
red demon you can do that too apparently
yes it is
let's go check out red
iron bowl right up there and uh oh he's
getting knocked on his butt it's pretty
great it's pretty great shunter's in the
chat says yes it is him he was also
james vega from mass effect 3. oh yeah
yeah that's that's right yeah i remember
that guy
could you buy it
why are you down what is what is going
on with you let's find her inventory
potions it's all good
so i feel like there there might be
i i might not have her set up set up
something
but uh i was initially off put by this
inventory system i feel like it's a
little lacking in terms of clarity of
what
what can be equipped where it can be
equipped who can be equipped by what it
does how to compare it to other things i
mean it took a little i i sort of get it
now but it took me a little bit to like
wrap my head around wasn't that kill the
goat immediately killing the ram because
it has meat
or skin i might i might need it's it's
hide um
though i i loot
everything are you ever over encumbered
uh yes you can you can uh run out of
inventory space um but there are ways to
increase your inventory space
um
through uh uh
you you earn uh points that you can
basically use to increase to do like
inquisition skills disappear there's
more bad guys you're just gonna go
listen i need to get leather
sorry you were saying i don't know i'm
not good at playing games and
talking at the same time um obviously
though i didn't handle this very well
but uh get to get uploaded yeah
open world tell me a little bit about
that like so it's not it's not open
world in the sense that something like
skyrim is open world
you know what i mean like like it's
an open world really yes lots of large
really large areas but you don't they're
not all accessible through like one
large map instead you have something
that's your health is very low i know
thank you
sweet so you've got you go to the map
and you choose different areas to go to
and then once you're in them for example
you're in the storm coast it's a really
sizable area with like multiple outposts
you can set up with
like quests that you're sent there to do
but then like a ton of quests you
discover while you're there and then
uh you know different characters will
sometimes have a quest that they in
particular are interested in and will
send you on uh as opposed to other
characters so you couldn't you couldn't
for instance like walk from the stalk
the storm coast to like to hinterlands
no no yeah you have to do that right but
the areas themselves are so large
that there's always
there's there's never really any point
where you're like gosh this is so
confining yeah you know it's not like
dragon age 2 where you were repeating
a lot of the same small areas you do
come back to these areas for for various
reasons but it's not like oh god they're
sending me back into that same dungeon
again it just it you know you're you're
seeing lots of different kinds of
climates
it's considering how long the game is
you said you played this for like 100
hours or so i i finished the story after
about 85 and that was sort of pushing
myself to get to the end of the story
towards the end because i'm really
easily distracted like by deep mushrooms
by deep mushrooms for example and then
there's another interesting thing is
where like you
you have big areas but you can't
necessarily get to all of the areas like
you'll come to places that are locked
off to you because there's some you know
a bridge down and you'll eventually have
to get that bridge repaired and you do
all of that stuff back at the back at
the war table like there's a lot of
stuff that you do back there at the war
table some of that sort of like
assassin's creed brotherhood where you
send out people and they accomplish
tasks for you
um and then you know once the time limit
has come they come back with whatever
potential reward and that's that's how
you unlock certain new areas
um
because it's not just about combat
sometimes it's about these other things
too
which is great because it kind of
diversif it makes you really feel like
you're part of this
it feels like you're part of a crew part
of this movement this inquisition like
it gives more form to the greater thing
it doesn't just feel like you and
your the guys that the three people
you're running around with it feels like
all the playable people you're with the
people on your war council and and it
just sort of feel like gives you this
way if it feels like you're exerting
influence
in a much richer way
uh which i really like have liked so far
i've played about eight hours or ten
hours of the game and influence is
actually more or less a currency you
know as you do things you earn influence
and then when you once you earn enough
influence
you know and enough power then you're
able to take take over some of the story
missions that are available to you
so
yeah there's there's there's such so
much to do oh look i'm at a leveling
point i've got uh
i've got people i can level this gives
us a chance actually to look at the
look at the skill trees and whatnot go
for it i'm guessing they are
vast this is me
um so in here
like i've i typically uh went
as you can see i did a lot of cold
um but i also threw in some spirit as
well
um
so i'm i'm thinking that i might i like
passive abilities when i can well you
don't have any points to spend for
yourself so this is revival
um
and this is this is something that i've
wanted to unlock for myself so
you don't have anything
i don't have anything to spend for
myself yeah i do already have that never
mind so do you never mind do you two
points for iron bowl do you mind
the upgrades for your party members or
because you can also just auto level you
can also just auto level them but
whatever who does that that's no fun
i've got a bunch of questions coming in
from the game swatch i kind of want to
get to before we get overrun here um is
there gamepad support on the pc yes
because mass effect 3 did not have that
yes
support it's weird though be careful
because there are like once you plug a
gamepad into the pc and decide to do pc
stuff um there are certain things that
you try like then there are certain
things on the keyboard that are not
available to you all right okay so for
example if you want a quick save you can
do that when using keyboard and mouse
but like you switch over to a you switch
over to controller and suddenly those
things are taken away really i just
never understood that what the hell how
is that like a
technical challenge for them right so
just put it in a menu instead of just
yeah anyway if you follow the buttons
pongley asks uh does the story progress
through the world linearly like an mmo
or does it let you quest around the map
like in skyrim oh i mean
sort of both i mean the story is going
to take you to different areas so that
you can unlock them and until you unlock
them you can't just venture into them
like in skyrim so in that sense you are
gated
um
sorry i get i get so easily distracted
but once you unlock that area you can go
wherever until there there might be some
other kind of gate like the kind i
mentioned before where the bridge is
down and you have to go back to the war
table to to do that i found myself being
able to play it in a sky in an open
worldly kind of way like i go to a place
to accomplish a specific goal like set
up five camps but then on route to the
camp i discover this quest or this thing
or get in this fight and oh there's like
i just spotted a castle up on that hill
actually i'd really like to go see that
uh i'll get i'll come back around to
that other thing so it it
there is that kind of exploratory
oh it's gameplay free that the minute
you're dropped in you can travel to any
place that will ever be available to you
ever in the game that's not how it works
uh lordlock is wondering uh has origin
reared its ugly head is it working fine
is there any problems with that stuff i
haven't heard of anything i think most
of the days
like technical launch issues people are
talking about are like things with uh
you play with ubisoft and far cry i
think people are a bit sensitive at the
moment
you play you play was this morning we
were trying to play far cry
on the pc oh really won't load can't log
into uplay
great yeah and for what it's worth the
master chief collection is still bored
the update patch that was scheduled for
tomorrow has been delayed
really yeah wow okay yeah happy
christmas and they're still working on
patching uh on unity as well which i'm
i'm told i think it's slightly better
these days maybe they'll patch a decent
irish accent into a subject
red hat drew asks is there any crossover
progress between the multiplayer and the
campaign or is it more like me three no
are you two different sets it's like me3
it's two very different things but
unlike me3 there is absolutely no
connection between the two of them and
me3 multiplayer could be used as sort of
a single-player progression
uh mechanic and that is not the case
here it is absolutely separate with no
um
nothing crossover no crossover at all
they're different different character
and so on so i went to dragon island
which is something i haven't done a lot
of um are the dragons on dragon island
yes so that's what i'm hoping is uh
maybe i'll i'll come across
i really like having a rogue a stabby
rogue in your party because then all of
a sudden you'll just see them up like
doing their stab dash thing cole is
great he's uh he's i mean every
character i i kind of love in their own
way in this game cole is interesting
because he's a spirit he's very
empathetic
he can read minds and he his goal is
essentially to comfort people that need
comfort
and he and when he describes what
in other people's thoughts he speaks in
this sort of
stream of consciousness poetry
that's
really appealing to me
like it's not often in games that you
get a character that's just so
empathetic and so caring about others
but not in that kind of cheesy way he
just feels like it's his mission to do
that and it's more of an ethereal
kind of kind of the way you describe him
kind of reminds me of thane uh oh
yeah kind of like that yeah the way that
he's sort of maybe not he's not you know
totally empathetic but he's just he's
he's different the way that he sort of
acts and
interacts and makes him like a really
intriguing character yeah kevin people
can read your uh thoughts on this on
gamespot of course i'm interested a
little bit into chris's insight
considering you did not play the other
two because i'm kind of in that same
boat as well i think mark is too so how
are you enjoying it at the moment i am
really loving it i mean i went home last
night and i had a copy of far cry 4 that
i'm playing to work on a gun show for
later this week uh but
i really just wanted to be playing this
cause it's just the
the mix like i'm really enjoying the
exploration the combat i'm enjoying so
far and like
collecting like meeting new people is
is a really good incentive like i love
it when games don't just incentivize
like
doing better in combat taking on bigger
enemies uh getting to new environments
but meeting new people and because it
means that that the characterizations in
that game are really interesting uh
that's a driving force for me uh so i've
really liked it and i i was a little
i wasn't too worried about sort of my
world state going into this right like i
don't have a dragon age origins or
dragon age too safe to import uh i
didn't realize it when i started my game
but there is
bioware did that thing where they've got
like a little web
game or story graphic novel thing you
can click through and kind of make the
big decisions did you do that i did not
i haven't done it uh
so this is if you haven't played those
games you can almost it's it's almost
like the toolkit for making your own
save game for walking dead or something
yeah you can just like do things you
want which i think is just like the the
greatest like i'm so glad that games do
that it's such a smart way to
uh
to lower the barrier for people who are
you know worried about like i really
want to know about this world when i get
into it so it really pays off for me
uh i think that's a really clever way to
go about it excellent last question
before we wrap this up danger up and i'm
messing this up so badly i'm gonna ask
you a question before he gets murdered
by a dragon antidote 2005 asks is the
combat system more like dragon age
origin no
no
um it's it's simply not um it's
it's it's sort of like that and it's
sort of not um it's not nearly as
tactical um in the sense that you can
play most of it from this third-person
view
um and and have a good time
um on the other hand you can switch to
this view
and do it but you only really need the
tactical camera
um during situations like this dragon
fights um exactly so you can
you know you can use it here and i one
one thing i love about it on console on
pc it's sort of different you do have to
stop and start like traditional balder's
gate dragon age origins kind of thing
but here you can just hold the trigger
okay forward time and then it forwards
time and then you can just go and do
whatever it is that you need to do sweet
like for example me
take some hot mess take some hot
maybe a confusion grenade we'll we'll do
something and then i can use it
more
but into thinking it's it's back left
leg ultimately i feel like that's
you know the best approach
that this game could have had
the reason i say that is because i can't
imagine that making
every
battle a big deal
like it would be if you were always
doing the tactical thing
would probably be a mistake the game
would draw out you're in large areas
you know i i think keeping it
relatively just on the fun side this is
probably the right it's probably the
right approach by the way this looks
and it looks
nice too
you're going to kill this dragon
no there's i don't know i'm not going to
be killing this dragon no
you got to guard down it's going to take
a while it's going to take a while all
right well this is dragon we will leave
it there then uh kevin valero thank you
so much thank you for talking to us
about dragonage inquisition uh it's
pretty long show today we've had a bunch
to talk about i guess that's sort of
fitting considering crazy review season
and that we're in we're going to get
jeremy jane and aaron sampson on with
kevin in just a few moments to talk
about far cry 4. we could have had
anyone on the couch for this because i
think everyone in the office we've all
played it in some way you're saying
yesterday the the elephant noise like
the amount of time elephant screaming
happens in the office has gone up by
like five million percent that's just
constant elephant screams coming from
ireland there's my first outpost with an
elephant yeah last night it was
wonderful i won that game so bad so
really i think you want that game uh you
can win it as well don't forget i can't
though you can't because your middle
name's video the one thing mark walton
can't
uh yeah retweet follow game spot and
retweet um what we done tweeted probably
about
an hour ago at this stage uh we'll be
back in a moment but far cry 4 we're
going to give that away
by the end of the show so make sure you
get on that right now maybe during this
little break but yeah we're gonna check
out possibly the most exciting patch
coming out in 2014 this is the goat
simulator mmo thing
yeah
all right
six months have passed since the latest
goat simulator patch
gamers have been requesting another free
expansion
now
the time has come for the lazy
developers to turn on their computers
once again
so
mmo simulator you can't make this stuff
we interviewed aaron at gdc and that
interview is going up as part of like uh
what we're calling goat simulator the
movie sometime in december once
everything's kind of quieting down
i'm convinced that they're doing all
this stuff because they feel so guilty
about all the people who bought it like
they have been so like we're going to
keep adding to this game and like doing
other versions and making sure that like
they had all those weird patches
obviously that's the first patch you've
done in like months and months now but
like they're so
like i don't know like
thankful but also a little bit freaked
out by all the people who bought it that
they're just like oh we'll just make
this massive mmo thing i mean can you
can you imagine a larger thing to add
though like an mmo simulator like they
couldn't have added anything that would
have seemed more grandiose than an enema
simulator i like the idea of them just
going into the uh the
map thing and just like the and just
like they're just throwing a few things
it's an mmo now on the presentation of
that like it's just that easy yeah to be
fair winner goats not epic this is true
goats are pretty much always fake that's
a good point i guess microwaves with
legs yeah yeah i don't know those those
guys seem to get it uh i'm looking
forward to playing that uh but again
we've been playing a bunch of this week
oh mary kish from downtown yes good job
jeremy jane there you go my friend hey
you and aaron and uh and rob and a bunch
of people have been pumping out some
sweet far cry 4 features yeah all week
long mostly just as an excuse to play
far cry
also i was just sitting so far cry has a
map editor on console oh yeah i was
literally just surrounding a wave of bad
guys with honey badgers i'm just
watching them all get eaten to death
excellent and or trampled oh you're
amazing what are you doing here swapping
in some guns yeah just uh getting some
guns ready for whatever we're gonna do
today uh if any folks have any questions
at all about far cry 4 please send them
in we've got three experts sitting on
the couch here
you flatter us
experts in killing goddamn honey badges
yeah jeremy you're an interesting
position whereby you have actually never
played uh you did not play far cry 3 is
that correct i played about a third of
far cry 3. okay and i played none of the
other far cry games right and i got a
little bored of far cry 3 i really i
really liked the idea of it but i just i
i don't know i couldn't get into it the
story was cool but it didn't suck me in
enough and it was just a little too much
like
mmo without the multiplayer aspect a
little too like fetch questy and i
honestly feel like maybe it was just my
attitude towards the game because this
one from what i gather is pretty similar
and not a whole lot different yeah
structure yeah this kind of feels like a
do-over in some ways yeah it feels like
a do-over far cry 3 it just with making
everything better more streamlined more
fun
see it's interesting because like i you
know all the far cry games up to this
point you know there there's a certain
kind of thing that they've all had but
they but each one is more or less kind
of different from the last so far cry 2
was very different from the original far
cry and then far cry 3 was much more in
that ubisoft formula than yeah you know
that they'd been developing for a while
than far cry 2 was this is the first
time in far cry where
and granted part of that's a different
developer
crytek made their name with the original
far cry before crisis
um
so but now it's a ubisoft thing and it's
interesting because far cry 4 really is
very much far cry 3. there's there's no
doubting it must
life
oh yeah get it
apollo created this one one thing i love
about this game is like
oh you know you're a hunter
you're a hunter but the wildlife clearly
fights back in this game yeah they're
not they're not like these innocent
little animals that don't get you they
want to eat your face just like
everything else in this world
and everything including the eagles all
the way oh yeah that's weird that is one
fun kind of new addition there was a
moment where where before i had seen a
bird attack
in this game where i had seen a bunch of
uh like freedom fighter dudes standing
around shooting in the air yeah and i
was like is this a bug yeah they were
shooting at something and i was like and
then it's like
it's like oh my god it's not a bug the
thing is the thing's attacking it's not
a bug
so it's interesting though because like
i
unlike aaron i don't necessarily see
everything so much as an improvement is
so much more of like a so like like
let's let's this is a terrible analogy
but let's go with it all right so let's
say that far cry 3 is a cake
far cry 3 is a cake and it's got icing
on it layers right like a lemon yeah
let's let's say yes imagine whatever
cake you like it's red velvet okay
whatever burger cake it's a murder
murder ooh with a blood frosting yeah
shoot that guy you can rip that proper
gun
very
anti-propaganda yeah
all of a sudden sexy probably um but uh
i think of far cry 4 as more like it's
okay so you have the good job i didn't
know what my mission was you've never
been playing
um so yeah
so this is more like the a cake but with
just the there's more icing
slathered on to it it's like so what can
we do oh i know we'll make it even
denser we'll make sure that every square
inch of land
leads you to something that the map is
so covered with icons
um and i think it also depends on kind
of what you're after when you play this
series like some people might generally
genuinely be after the story the yeah
you know the story with voston far cry 3
was was genuinely like pretty cool yeah
at least that aspect of this yeah he was
a great villain until he spoilers
okay but if you play this game as a
sandbox then then that's why like that's
why i view this as a big improvement is
because i a lot of times i just view the
story in this game as a way to open up
new areas as opposed to the reason why i
play this game i play this game because
you can off-road and like kill cheetahs
and wingsu through crazy avenues and
just like the whole insanity of it this
one adding co-op you have a friend doing
it with you
um this one has climbing which i love
and the story to me is just sort of the
sideshow you find the story quite
abrasive right i i hate the story of far
cry 4 with a passion um what's what's
interesting
do a different question
what's interesting to me though is is
that and it's especially was true
because like
i was playing this when the just cause
three announcement came out and what was
interesting is that one of the things
that really irritates me about far cry 4
is that it it so badly wants to shove
things in your face that you don't
necessarily want to be doing but that
it's like like listen do this and do
this and do this okay so one of my least
favorite things that happens in the game
is that you take over an outpost and you
leave
and then this happens
yeah you're like the outpost is under
attack you should come and shave it so i
go back and do it i leave ten seconds
later it's like the outpost is under
attack but you have to do that you don't
but then when you don't it's like you
failed
protect the other kills
is there anything screw you like
whatever guys you got this don't worry i
got a gyrocopter another another thing
what will happen though is when it
happens okay so let's say i set my
waypoint and it has a kind of this cool
auto drive thing it's not it's not
perfect by any stretch i love that being
in the video review
but you have to sort of pay attention to
what's going on because it'll just run
into things it's it's not like it's go
for a wonder yeah
but what will happen is the game will
freaking change your waypoint for you
all really and like during one of those
times it's like you know what leave me
alone
leave me alone leave me well f youtube
i got a bunch of questions coming in i
just want to get to them pretty quick uh
red hat drew's asking is probably for
you aaron how deep is the map editor
i just started digging into it recently
but it seems like you can pretty much
pull out any terrain any animal just
about any bad guy you can make your own
bases
um set up the alarms for the bases so it
seems pretty extensive it depends on
where your history with map editors is
though it's i mean it's pretty user
friendly for what it is yeah yeah um so
it's easy to go in and just shut put a
bunch of stuff around and create kind of
a sandbox what's like
what's the end goal of it can you share
with other people is it just to make
kind of dumb scenarios or is it like
like forge kind of inhaler where you're
just playing around with it for fun
yes yeah you can't share it with other
people i mean you can go in and uh
um it wasn't there wasn't a whole lot
when i was playing it because of course
it hadn't been really stalled you know
public yet but but you can share that
stuff and then you can go in and check
out what other people are making
although it strikes me it's more of a
you know it's more of a like here's a
sandbox thing it'll be a novelty for
around
people i mean if you're dedicated you
could probably make something pretty
incredible out of it i wonder how large
you can like have either of you
experimented with you know the
constraints of how much you can put into
a map editor world before it sort of
starts reeling you back in i don't
really play with it enough to know like
how far i can really stretch it right
i'm kind of curious to see what people
do with it um especially because those
people will be probably more maybe more
interested in that stuff than i am
although i think i don't know like how
many people really come to it for that i
mean it really is all about the sandbox
right and that's one of the things so
intriguing about this game is that the
sandbox is so good and yet it goes out
of its way so often to take you away and
it was like if if i had to choose b for
sandbox purposes if i had to choose
between far cry 4 and just cause 2 i'd
actually choose just clause 2. i'd
actually choose far cry 3 for that
matter because some of the things
like on one hand you get new cool tools
like the gyrocopter and
elephants getting on an elephant is one
of the best things and they're so good
my favorite mission in the game is one
where you just got an
and it's one that you might not even
perform because there are branching
missions so you might not even do this
mission but if you do like it's it's
basically like get on an elephant again
just like bring you bring down this
whole chimney on this drug manufacturing
plant just falls right over
so but but on the other hand there's
stuff like i miss sharks okay i mean you
do have demon fish there are distempered
piranhas in this game yeah so yeah
but you can basically more or less just
it's super easy to kill one from just
the shore yeah jeremy and i did go
dynamite fishing we did did it work
it didn't it totally worked oh there's a
great if you watch the co-op piece
there's this one great shot where aaron
takes an explosive arrow and shoots it
at a fish and it was the first time we
tested it and i kind of didn't expect it
to work i thought it was sort of like a
water blocks all like explosives kind of
video game mechanic nope and it had this
like one second delay where it hit and
exploded and i was kind of like oh it
didn't work and the fish just was
soaring into the air really
it was so good i never had i never had a
demon fish go soaring into the air i did
have uh like my favorite part of your
co-op video was
so with the gyrocopters your co-op buddy
can attach to the bottom
of the air like a yeah with your grapple
hook so you grapple you grapple to the
like the lower end of that and my
favorite thing that you guys did is go
up and there was a helicopter sorry go
ahead and uh it's you know you usually
helicopter and far cry 3. it's like
you're on the ground you get a rocket
launcher that's how you take care of the
helicopter in this case
like you you pulled the other dude up
and you just basically shot guns
like pilots in the face and then the
thing goes spiraling down because it no
longer has a pilot it's like that is the
most ridiculous thing you shot guns it's
interesting the heavy the gyrocopter
does sort of give you that just cause
two ability to get up in the air yeah
and with the wing suit i i think for me
it's a toss-up between just cause 2 and
far cry 4 because just the pleasure of
being up in the air in the freedom of
either parachuting or wing suiting
combined with a grappling hook like
mechanic i think leads to some of the
best gameplay moments i've seen in a
long time yeah it's weird though because
one another thing i prefer just cause
two for is that
like it's
good job
it's not so in your face with a lot of
other things ubisoft games just love
their kind of like look how edgy we are
kind of thing like yeah
and far cry 4 is no exception to that
and so there are these things that like
i hate get sometimes i hate getting in
vehicles and driving places like because
radio radio free curat um oh god they're
they're really two radio stations one is
pagan men's um official propaganda
propaganda you gotta buy one party
others yeah the other is uh is radio
freak who is
it every character is just worse than
the last that gets introduced in this
game and
like i i i don't know like if they're
trying to be like i think it's supposed
to be funny yeah but when you're like
going down the road and the radiant
officer is like you know if i were a
serial killer what i would do is instead
of instead of leaving a mask as my
calling card i'd i'd smear my victims
with [__] oh yeah that was a weird
conversation and he's like going on and
i thought and i'd be like
there's a killer on the loose there is a
killer on there you have mass that
you're finding but i don't think you
keep cauterizing your wounds like arrows
arrows out of your arm
it's a video game kids don't try this at
home yeah jesus christ but it can be a
little bit weird because like every time
you actually do something the game
pushes you to do it's like why so i
almost never hear the radio because i
always use the gyrocopters to get places
i always fast travel to wherever there's
a gyrocopter yeah that was one huge
improvement in this game although far
cry 3 was not bad with it but the fast
travel was a huge problem in far cry 2.
yeah yeah you have to go on the edges of
the map to get the bus stations yeah
also i was watching video reviews this
is for far cry
you're everywhere do you guys remember
malaria everywhere yeah yeah that was
people i mean i don't know that i i
would say that it's it's universally
considered bad though because far cry 2
was at least very interesting okay let's
get into the conversation this is far
cry 4 everyone seems to be enjoying it
uh up to a certain level at least some
more than others yeah
far cry is like the weirdest series in
the world because the first game and
second game have nothing to do with each
other
largely far cry two and three
nothing to do with it and this is the
first time that the series has actually
had any sort of through thread and
whatsoever so let for the four people
here in the studio at the moment which
is the best far cry dragon what blood
dragon
audible there okay i would okay so so
ultimately
it depends on what i'm going for if i'm
coming for sandbox i actually think that
overall far cry 3 is a better game than
far cry 4. yeah um and all and
mechanically a better game
best game in the series
um so i would go with far cry 3 i think
its missions are better than far cry 4's
missions i think that um
it
yeah just as for cohesion purposes yeah
i would go with that but i think the
most interesting game in the series is
far cry 2 yeah and the one that deserved
the that deserves more credit than it
gets but i don't know i mean you're
looking at games that are all in some
place in the good spectrum you know
these are all quality games that are all
good in some way so part of it's just
gonna be sort of what you come for
two is a weird one because two is a game
that like the people who really love to
like champion too they really freaking
love you too right were you much of a
fan of far cry 2 at all far cartoon it
was you know again i come to this series
for its sandbox aspects i i literally
don't know if i ever found the story in
far cry 2. yeah because i was pretty
much busy just using dune buggies to run
over gazelles
and and basically taking over bases
i'm so sorry and okay so there's one
thing i really did not like about far
cry 2 which was that there were these
diamonds everywhere and you had this map
that it was a physical map you pulled up
in front of your face and i spent so
much of that game with a map and staring
at the map driving with it like i never
wrapped up i like i never saw the game
because it was always behind a map
and i couldn't not get the diamonds
because of gamer compulsion yeah so like
that kind of ruined far cry 2 for me
between that and the fast travel being
so far out on the edges of the map the
audio used to drive me crazy in far cry
2 as well because it was it had to have
been sped up it sounds like they didn't
have as much room on there yes the audio
so whenever people spoke
there was there were no they didn't
speak in a natural way everything felt a
little sped up and it felt like there
was almost no time between people's
conversations with each other like they
were just like run on sentences that
people kept
so it was a weird game but i also think
it deserves credit for for being as
different as it was and and for
for like people some people don't like
malaria but i got to give them alert
some people don't like malaria yeah i'm
a huge guy i gotta give the valerian
credit
for
you know
for being daring far cry 3 is more a
game for compulsive people i'm going to
give a big shout out to far cry 1
because this is like
totally first
one of my favorite first person shooters
ever it's 10 years old this year
actually as well it was march 04. you
just like the mutants didn't you all go
back okay it could be hard to go back
the trajans were
kind of awful like that game turned into
something
really different like almost like when
the hunters turn up in resident evil 1
and you're like oh come on do you
remember the final boss of the original
far cry it was dr krieger yeah the guy i
know that i know that bang bang bang oh
you're the guy archer right what happens
yeah
he's basically just you shoot him he's
gone and it's over i remember that
because that same year doom three came
out and also had a bad guy called
krieger it was like doc did two doctor
kriegers and two first persons she
actually didn't mind the trigens but the
thing is the german story the original
far cry so first of all it actually had
it at least had the most the best
protagonist in the series because he had
a freaking personality and he actually
had a character so jack carver oh yeah
and it had a great opening cut scene
because it had this like that in in one
moment like it it had this like rewind
scene from when the from when the boat
explodes
so that was cool but then there's this
moment so it you don't begin in the open
you know you sort of begin indoors and
you the first time you you walk past the
window and you can look out and it's
like
yeah you're like oh my god and then
you're like am i going to go on and then
you go out and just like
holy [__] look at this place and you're
like can i go to these places like well
actually yes yeah it was 2004. this was
kind of like this place before large
open world kind of like what we're used
to fall out in skyrim and stuff like
that having these sort of these grand
worlds like there was an aspect of that
in some of the older elder scrolls games
but never like a first person shooter
where there was multiple ways of
attacking like kind of project igi style
almost yeah and then you go underwater
and it's like oh my god it was kind of
cheesy in a bit because you saw like the
water bubbles around you it was a little
cartoony but it's like oh my god look at
this place it was good and it was
beautiful it was a game that everyone
upgraded their graphics card for totally
free because that was the first game
that year but then between doom 3 coming
out and half life 2 coming out later
that year oh yeah 2004 was amazing yep
doom doom 3 did come out that year and
uh well unreal 2004 came out uh
the year before
was it the year before was it in 2004 i
forgot something wants to i cause i want
to say
that it was that it was
still um
i want to say that it really was early
2004 the reason i remember far cry's
original release is because it was my
birthday all right in march did you get
it for your birthday i did get it for my
birthday
so and then i re and then at the same
time i was playing unreal tournament
2004. so i'm trying to remember a fun
real tournament 200 came out anyway like
in january or something or whatever but
anyway and then it was fun because then
um then crisis came out around my
birthday
um so i feel like for a while crytek's
thing was released games on kevin's
we almost gave far cry go to the
birthday present as well jason akampo
actually wanted to give it a 10. yeah
yeah
scale back down obviously after yeah
after some deliberations in the game
deliberations yeah but it's a great
series it's it's almost the interesting
thing about saying which version of uh
far cry is the best is unlike something
like i don't know resident evil or
uh maybe
maybe not like a solid but like some
series where there are obvious like down
trends and up trends far cry kind of
in though it's been kind of
idiosyncratic it kind of had a game for
everyone like you haven't played much of
the old ones at all but you're a big fan
of four now yeah no i i mean i'm also
sort of partial to well the big
difference for me between three and four
is the environment and like they could
be
stock the same exact engine which you
know they're not obviously but like it's
it's that like murky jungle about three
that didn't really do it for me
everything just felt sort of like samey
yeah there's there's so much verticality
to this map and i think like the wing
suit was great in far cry 3 but for some
reason in this it's just like like i'll
go out of my way to climb up hills just
so i can fly off of them like it's so
interesting
what it does sometimes though is it
makes me miss
having uh just cause two's uh particular
brand of grapple hook yeah yeah and and
things so i've because i felt like it
was a lot more joy to get around that
way because you could although that game
was super challenging to have the best
grapple hook of any grapple hook in any
games or ever i mean the fact that you
could attach objects to other objects
just made that game incredible
are you parachuting now a second
okay i was gonna even get over the
waterfall i couldn't tell because you
were going oh there we go oh passion
over the waterfall oh i don't think he's
gonna make it do it do it do it do it
hit it hit it hit it hit it
oh leaning in the water though why
didn't you hit parachutes
do it this time
oh that's true imagine if you saw a man
hang gliding and then he let go of his
hand glider and you're like holy [__]
what's wrong with you
all right
you can do it you guys have a good video
too i embedded it in the review actually
of doing basically a long wings
oh that was yeah almost
a lot of fun one funny thing about far
cry 4 because the sandbox is such a
pleasure to be in it's weird but a lot
of the bugs that happen in this game i
find kind of endearing yeah yeah like it
could be skyrim issues actually
like i don't get aggravated a lot of
times i'm just laughing my ass off when
something happens like jeremy and i were
running on a base uh with elephants and
like my elephant stepped on a landmine
and then just started like spinning
non-stop over and over and over again it
was terrifying i felt really bad for it
there was a convoy that i was supposed
i'm gonna try and the wingsuit again
there's a convoy that i was supposed to
chase an armored convoy and it spawned
in right in front of me one of the bad
guys just got ejected like 20 feet off
the back of the convoy for no reason
whatsoever it was hilarious
so yeah like this game
it's weird like when this game breaks it
usually breaks in ways that
i just kind of find hilarious it's never
broken away from me that was like uh
there was a game at all yeah yeah i mean
every so often stuff would happen where
it's like because it kept like trying to
remind me of to do to do quests i'd
already done like an hour before and so
stuff like that can be a little annoying
because there's there's there's no
entertainment value in that but there
certainly is entertainment while you're
watching that elephant spin around in
circles can you guys speak to the
current situation with you play with
this on pc have you guys played at this
point i haven't played it i heard mark
say something like there was a bit of
trouble with it there was my
understanding
the the the two here we go i was
watching ubisoft's tweets this morning
and they said that they got it fixed
okay but i haven't actually played and i
know actually that there were problems
with multiplayer on ps4 and ps3 i was
having some gameplay issues i'm not sure
what was going on with it i don't know
if you play is really known as the
sterling service nope
that's sure
why did we need this sort of service
yeah all right let's do this games are a
service now you know they're not
released or sold they're launched game
games for windows live that's the with
the we can blame for all of this these
trucks are actually the reason why they
have barely gotten through any of the
storyline mm-hmm did you head down
trucks all the time yeah because you
basically you're heading somewhere and
then one of these trucks come along and
all you want to do is get the truck uh
especially the the grenade launcher
sidearm kevin you turned me onto that i
i wasn't even using that i didn't
realize it was the best sidearm in the
game is the grenade launcher and you can
pick it up really early
you need it for everything
it's terrible though because i lost all
my karma because every time i drive by
another car i'm like you know i could
just blow it up real quick like i could
just plug one grenade into it you could
just plug one grenade into this guy yeah
give me your vehicles
don't help them just grenade up now
there's another vehicle well i guess you
gotta fix it first
you got it this is like a fake out
you're like oh i love you guys
you're like oh why don't i help you
change the tire and then you carjack
them i gotta come and do this can i
throw out a a quick shout too because we
didn't cover all of the far crys in the
sense that there were that there was
like far cry instincts oh god oh god
and and stuff like that so so the game
came to like the original xbox as well
as the xbox 360. far cry instincts
predator yes it was far cry instincts
and then far cry instincts predator yeah
which were both hot trash
so the the series has found its lows
yeah as well ubisoft didn't really know
what to do it at the start i think it's
fair to say yeah they eventually found a
home for with on far cry 3. well then
they then they hit an open world formula
that they can apply to every single game
that they make forever and exactly
watchdogs assassins creed both
assassin's creeds the crew this but i i
think out of all of them surprisingly
enough i think the first person open
world
thing has been like there have been more
successful first person open world games
this far cry 2 like the way the elder
scrolls series has evolved like the way
fallout as a whole sort of gta yeah
grand theft auto
person like i kind of want to see more
and more of these games there's there
seems to be i don't know when
when they put the effort into making
that game and this weird little subject
three is coming out like that's gonna
come out like holy like suddenly people
that like see the thing that's
interesting though is working that was
great
sorry case in point
my worry though is please finish the
games before
and this year has been a really weird up
and down year for i mean i hate i hate
the term aaa um but for lack of a better
word for big budget games this this has
been a weird year for big budget games
either things that were expected to be
good weren't good or things are broken
um it's it's a really strange year for
the big budget game
anyway it's been a it's been fun talking
about the playing a bunch of them today
on the show and i'm talking about the
crazy review uh schedule uh we got to
get back to
review more games i see coming in the
pipeline um yeah and we've got to make
some some hot video as well so uh yeah
kevin thank you very much for staying on
the show all day today oh god
back to the real world uh jeremy and
aaron as well for your expertise on far
cry 4.
thank you for having us man that's the
show
whoa it's not a show thank you very much
what would we do in our married fish
thank you mary
mary come here
hold up sit here sit here sit here
sit here it's hairy don't care if you
don't
you heard a new first folks winner's
there to the left
the winner is
gamer for life
three for an e
and a four for a four
you won
you did this now you're a gamer for even
more of your life
am i doing it right am i holding the
microphone
how much do you think this is worth
i think this is without going over
149 shekels oh 150 shekels
gotcha
this is the show uh thanks for watching
um tune in next week we'll have more
amazing games i'm danny o'dwyer
and that's it bye everyone
you